hello folks
welcome to
rational science
directly from frankfurt germany
and it's uh nine o'clock over here at
night
anyways we have a busy day today and so
i'm gonna get right to it okay
we're gonna cover this today we're gonna
look at a fellow by the name of walter
russell okay
and then we're gonna look at a uh flat
earther and uh by the name of boston he
talks about the ether we're gonna be
analyzing his ether
i made a video about a week ago and so
i'll be looking at that someone uh
referred him to me uh we're going to
look at the main topic today which is
the definition of definition what is a
definition specifically
a scientific
definition right
and uh then we're gonna look at our
science critic okay
and uh
he made a video some time ago and uh 45
minute video and so we're analyzing
piece by piece
everything that he had to say about the
scientific method then i'm going to open
up the
floor for questions and comments
especially the ones that people made
since last time
okay so let's get on with it uh let me
get rid of this here in a second here
okay so here we go okay we have this um
issue here a fellow raises a question or
he makes a comment and he says the
following materialist
logical fallacy begins with rejecting
scripture
okay so he started by rejecting uh or
accepting scripture right he says anyone
who rejects scripture
is already uh
entering in some kind of materialistic
uh fallacy okay
uh the world is divided between two
kinds of people essentially for the
purposes of physics
and
99
of the people in the world are
spiritualists
and they have no idea what physics is
about
they explain things in terms of
god angels spirits
they use concepts they move concepts
around
we have all these people out there who
have all these abstractions and they
want to do physics with abstractions
and when all else fails the
spiritualists some of the extreme ones
especially those uh who are
tied to traditionalist
religions they just say well it's all
god
you know
and uh yeah with that they haven't
explained anything and they didn't
understand anything they don't care to
understand anything they just want to
tell you that they know
and knowledge implies god that's it
that's as far as their knowledge goes
and the material is probably one percent
of humanity okay and those are the only
ones who can ever be physicists okay
why is that
well in order to be
a physicist you need to know the golden
principle of physics
here's the golden principle okay
memorize it say it in your prayers at
night every night okay here it goes
okay the golden principle of physics
physics requires an object you can't do
physics without an object
okay
[Applause]
and uh people say well why do you need
an object well
imagine that there's nothing at all in
the universe no object no nothing
what is happening
what are you imagining what are you
visualizing
you know i mean there's nothing going on
without objects you need objects to do
physics okay
and so those people who explain
with uh abstract concepts such as the
mathematicians of the
establishment
uh well they have a problem because
they're using um essentially spirits
to do their physical interpretations
their mechanisms and so they put in
there
the uh concepts you know energy and mass
and uh
force
time they work time you know and do all
these fancy things
and they're all doing what they're doing
is uh moving concepts around
okay
and
that ain't physics okay that's known as
religion
all of mathematical so-called physics
not mathematic mathematics something
else mathematics is equations numbers
operations that's something else but
when the mathematician ventures crosses
the line
into physics
now he's doing religion
math is math physics is physics never
the twain shall meet
okay and it's when people from the
mathematical world cross over the line
and say oh i can tell you how this
universe works
okay tell me
and you say okay how does gravity work
how does magnetism work you know here
you have uh two magnets
okay
how does that work how did that happen
what what caused this to happen okay
and they say well i can give you a
mathematical description
that's not what i asked i asked for an
explanation i want a mechanism
and if they're going to do it with
concepts you know say there's a field
what is a field please draw it i want to
see what kind of physical object the
field is
so you have to begin by drawing it by
showing me pointing to
the object the thing you call field
that's the issue
and of course they can't do that because
field is a concept in fact if you look
up the word a field is simply a bunch of
numbers
extending radially from ground to zero
and getting weaker and weaker from that
point
that's all the field is it's a bunch of
numbers a bunch of magnitudes so there
is no physical standalone object like a
table called field
that's the problem
and so uh this fellow here um
russell
wally russell he was a mystic he was an
ascetic yeah he
he had little birdies in his head you
know he thought in the abstract mode he
didn't do physics with physical objects
okay that was
his downfall i guess and he does have a
few followers out there and i'm going to
talk about a couple of them today
anyways uh this was uh wally and uh what
does he say well uh russell said one day
he had this moment of enlightenment
nirvana i guess he he saw the light
light shone on his brain i guess and he
said i could perceive all motion and was
newly aware of all things
oh my god
uh bartender i want to drink whatever he
drank
okay so yeah he had a moment of
enlightenment suddenly he saw the light
so what does he say
uh what is it that he saw
did god touch his head with god's hand
you know
so the cardinal era of science is
shutting the created creator out of his
creation
oh my god
so he's gonna do everything with god
he's going to have the hand of god
uh work in there do the miracles for him
okay that's how he's going to i guess
explain
mechanisms of physics physical
interpretations
so he said god is the invisible
motionless sexless no god is sexless
yeah i guess he doesn't have a belly
button right no mother
um
undivided and unconditioned white
magnetic light of mind which centers all
things
what a bad start
you know for a physicist you know if you
want to be a physicist you want to come
into physics you want to
talk about physical interpretations how
magnetism works how gravity works how
light works the atom and so on
this is a bad start
you know
the guy says oh you know uh
let me bring god into the room
that's how he starts i mean nothing
wrong with you believing in god you want
to believe in god no problem go out
there and do your sunday school stuff
but when you come into physics
you can't bring god with you sorry okay
because when you bring god with you what
you're doing is bringing the magic wand
you're doing magic black magic
you're going to say that the curtain
moved because your great-grandmother
spirit came back or something from
heaven you know or something along those
lines
and now uh
those are not valid explanations
rational explanations in physics okay so
he continues says god is provable by
laboratory myth
he's gonna prove god with some kind of
experiment i guess you know maybe
mix two
liquids produce god you know like uh
aladdin's lamp you know rub it and the
genie comes out i guess that's the
experiment he had in mind said the
locatable motionless light which man
calls magnetism is the light which god
is
oh man i'm glad he finally discovered
you know how magnetism works it says
religion and science must come together
in a new age
so i guess he preceded uh or
you know the templeton foundation that
tries to unite
uh
physics or science and
religion
yeah there's not much more to say about
uh poor little old wally you know uh he
he had no idea about anything he was a
mystic
okay um you know nirvana maybe too many
viewers who knows what but he's still a
popular guy among some minority groups
some dissidents out there
and um
and here we have uh
one of them who was uh
nicola tesla okay tesla said the
following about mr russell
and says lock up this cosmic knowledge
in a safe for 1 000 years until man is
ready for it
yeah
good old nicholas uh he um he also was a
mystic okay he he
ultimately said that everything is god
you know so he had these ideas about
how to run physics he was he was not a
scientist uh tesla i mean neither one
neither russell or tesla they were not
scientists they were
in the case of tesla he was just an
offender
and it was easy more or less for him to
invent things in his days
because we were just starting with
electricity and building gadgets for the
first time the light bulb edison and so
on you know
and um
and so
in those days one person could still
invent some stuff out there
today you know like in the industry i
work with uh or for uh semiconductors it
takes a whole bunch of people to create
a chip
things have gotten a lot more
complicated you can't have just one guy
out there invent something you know as
complicated as a chip or develop it
further you know you need a whole team
and so the inventions are becoming more
and more uh difficult but in the days of
tesla you know we were just discovering
he was a he had he was a sharp guy for
that kind of thing he he had a good
intuition
and so he invented things how do you
invent things
you know uh and edison his his ex boss
right he ron tesla went to work for
westinghouse but
uh said it correctly he said i have not
failed
i've just discovered 10 000 ways that
don't work
and that was uh essentially a summary of
uh
technology technology is developed by
trial and error okay
and it has nothing to do with science
whatsoever science explanations
you need to explain a mechanism that's
what science is and tesla could never
explain anything in fact uh one of the
problems with both tesla and russell is
that they use the words i covered the
other day you can't use any of these
words in science
if you make your case with any of these
words
you are a religious fanatic you are not
a scientist okay so if you see your
words in there okay
force field energy mass time wave charge
ether
electricity
plasma density gravity and so on down
the line uh if you use any of these
words to make your case in science
uh you've stepped into the wrong uh
forum you know you should take this to
your uh sunday school preacher okay
but as an idiot an idiot is a theos with
big ideas okay and so uh
that's uh the type of people who use
these forbidden concepts okay we don't
use any of these concepts in science in
physics okay
so if you're using any of these concepts
it means they were shoved up your nose
holes right
in high school by the mathematicians
they put those words in your mouth
so if you spit out any of these words
and you say oh force it was the field it
was the wave
vortex
electricity did it
then uh it means you got all these words
from the mathematical establishment okay
that's what it is okay
that's where you got him
okay so uh this is what russell had to
say about light okay he said uh
whether light is car muscular as newton
claimed it to be or a wave right there
is much evidence in favor of both
theories
and what does he conclude says it is
both
okay that's a good way of being at peace
with both god and the devil okay it's
both it's a particle and it's it is also
a wave okay
and uh he goes on there he says there be
need be no mystery as to whether light
is carbuscular or wave for waves of
motion which simulate the light and
darkness of space are all there is
okay this is this is his assessment it
turns out that he's not going to vouch
for the postular
version at all he was completely away
theorist because at no point does he
mention
uh the corpuscle the particle okay
he never defends it in fact he says even
the corpuscle is is a wave he says light
is expressed by motion okay all motion
is wave motion
okay i don't know if that's true but uh
he got that from the quantum folk all
waves are expressed by fields of equal
and opposite pressures of two-way motion
well there's no such thing as a field uh
mr wally okay uh so
and whenever you use any word like wave
or field he's talking nonsense he
continues as all space within wave
fields is curved
oh my god so we have curved space
again
uh that happens after the 10th beer
usually okay
all matter is wave motion he says
together these constitute what we call
matter and space it has been difficult
to conceive light as being purely
corpuscular for light is presumed to
fill all space
okay so light is everywhere right but we
don't know what light is so all he says
it's just a wave motion that's all it is
and then he says space is not empty it's
not empty
well space is not a thing
mr wally so um you know to say space is
empty or full is is nonsense
space is a synonym of nothing nothing is
that which doesn't have shape you cannot
fill that which doesn't have shape
okay
and uh he says it is full of wave motion
so space is full of no motion okay
that's great a lot of movement and we
still don't have an object we don't know
what's moving
corpuscular
corpuscle
corpuscles of matter are one half of
wave cycles of light space is the other
half
yeah this poor fella he did not make
much sense at all
and therefore he was not a physicist he
was just a amateur uh
you know a religionist he was a
spiritualist he did everything with
spirits
now he has some followers in modern day
uh
world okay
and i'm going to talk about two of them
okay
and one of them is this fellow and his
name is
robert audi
okay robert addy
and uh he
uh styles himself as a
cosmologist uh he is a sacred
geometrician he believes in sacred
geometry
and he obviously uh
is a follower of russell he
vouches for uh resilient
science okay he claims to be agnostic um
and just in case uh that's not the same
thing as an agnostic okay
uh gnosticism the belief that human
beings contain a peace of god within
themselves which has fallen from the
immaterial world into the bodies of
humans
okay so you can see uh where this poor
fellow is coming from
okay
and uh he's a mystic also uh cosmic
jester i guess he's a clown okay
shamanic
voyeur maybe he said voyager maybe he
just confused the words he's an
environmentalist uh he does a lot of
water research
water researcher
all i can tell them is that you know
water is very easy you know just uh
h2o
that's it that's all you need to know
about water
anyways robert dottie currently works as
a foreman of a horse ranch and a master
gardener caring for the animals walnut
and fruit trees
uh orchards and organic gardens on our
ranch and this was from 2012
why do i mention mr adi okay uh and i
think uh
i would remove some letters from his
name
uh he likes to call him james robert
aute or
ok or something along those lines i
guess he thinks he's french or something
and
actually i'd rather remove some letters
from his name and call him
you know
robot okay
because the other day he came to my site
here and he uh put a lot of comments
okay he put a lot of comments uh
repeated comments
some people thought that maybe he was um
using a bot of some kind
okay
and it was not nice uh what he was doing
now you know i don't mind people coming
here and
cussing my mother out
yeah no problem i have no problem with
that at all in fact uh i think it's good
uh for two reasons one it means that uh
they hate me so much that means that i
tickled them okay
and that's good and then the other one
is you know i want to be honest if they
hate my guts i don't want you to butter
me up
just tell me how how you really feel so
in both cases it's good and i have no
problem people doing that
but see when you put a lot of
comments like gazillions of comments one
right after another and you're just
swamping the site
well you're not bothering me as much but
you're bothering other people you're
getting into you're interfering with
communication
and so i can ask uh good old bobby
robbie
the uh robot
to
you know behave okay
now it's important to understand where
the spell is coming from okay
and uh and why he
comes here so often you know
and uh here's a comment that i made to
him this was in 2012 okay about the time
that uh he posted his bio okay
robert audio free energy was upset when
i told him there was no such thing as
energy vortices waves
okay and that really upset him
fortunately all the idiots of his group
decided to stop following me on youtube
thank god okay
it's good to weed out the rubbish
separate the men from the mice so to
speak science is not about number of
hands but about rational explanations
you can't sacrifice one for the other
so yeah uh robbie has been following me
since then
and that's quite creepy
please don't follow me
okay
um
but despite all his uh
degrees and
you know
what he boasts about
um robbie had a problem okay a few years
ago in fact he had i think a couple
problems okay uh
his ranch burnt down
in northern california because there was
a wildfire over there
and
uh there were several in fact up there
and so he had a lot of trouble because
of that in fact fema came in there and
moved them out and put them into
trailers i think i think the one in 2012
he wasn't very happy about that then he
went back and he had another
fire over there some people say it was
made by bill gatey maybe
okay maybe i did it i'm sorry i didn't
mean to
anyways you can see the population has
been dropping in that region okay a lot
of people are leaving
why is that well here you have a comment
from the wikipedia says with the
destruction of most upper
unpermitted structures and forced during
the 2008 fires
the pattern of residences commercial
land use and formal and formal market
industries and recreational use has
changed there has not been any
large-scale residential development in
the region the baby boomer bulge
was expected to result in a steady
stream of retirees into the region
uh to date however the population has
declined despite the retirees
okay so what happened is yeah you know
the land that he purchased uh probably
is worth half as much today so he's
probably not happy about that but he
styles himself as a big horticulture and
you know that he plants and he's got
gardens and so on uh you know i don't
think so and here's an interview he
conceded a couple years ago
okay and this is what he says he says my
ranch was burned to the ground 7 45 a.m
only a little over an hour after it
started in pogus where the fire began my
cabin caught on fire on both sides and i
ran through 30 foot long flames being
driven by 60 miles per hour winds in a
huge fire boardings
uh he used the word vortex because he's
a fanatic of these uh vortices right
but there you can see that he fell on
hard times and says if you would like to
support robert go to his website and
there you have it the uh his famous
uh what is it free energy and free
thinking uh site okay
um
again why do i mention him well because
uh this all has very little to do out
there
and so what he does is he uh goes to
sites especially my site and he bombards
me with stuff and that's no problem i
have no problem with that at all really
i don't uh but again if he interferes
with communication by posting
you know many
uh repeated comments
uh he's interrupting communication for
other people that's a little different
okay
so i have a problem with that part
anyways um
uh because he's uh
i i imagine him in his little hut like
ted kaczynski
you know he's the guy who sent all these
bombs out there by mail
mail order bombs
and this guy's angry at the world he
talks about love
he's a fanatic of love
but he doesn't love humankind he's angry
at mankind and so he goes out there and
uh he has a lot of trouble everywhere
and if you go to his site uh you'll find
something like this you know you'll find
uh youtube has
deleted all his videos okay
and terminated his accounts many times
and so what he does is creates all these
sock puppets
okay
and uh he creates one every day almost
uh why because um he he gets banned
constantly he doesn't behave very well
out there again you know maybe
ted kaczynski type maybe one day he'll
send a bomb to someone yeah who knows
anyways uh this is uh what robbie has in
his site if you decide to go in there it
says many vastly when this is just one
article that
that essentially you know tells a lot
about him there's many vastly different
gods are worshiped by the descendants of
the european invaders who populate the
usa so which god are these politicians
asking
to bless us
north america otherwise known as turtle
island
is the land of the native god uh
guantanamo okay i never hear his name
mention the politics by the politicians
why
as the great spirit in sacred mystery
which is called the everything or the
one took breath it inhaled with
implosive force it's too lucky and thus
discovered its female being
uh-huh maybe that
uh resonated with him the fact that he
discovered his female being or something
this creative receptive force became the
egg of all creation known as the
wakan uh the universe or sacred
grandmother then uh guantanamo exhaled
and in doing so discovered its male side
okay so we have this male and female
side the active conceptive force the
seed of all creation
known as the sakuan the galaxy you are
sacred grandfather etc etc
okay so if you go to your site that's
about the best you're gonna get you're
gonna get stuff like that
so you can see why he's a follower of
russell
okay and what what little birdies he's
got in his head
and yeah because nobody
pays attention to him and he really
craves attention
he's angry at the world
and he forgets about love
that he talks so much about okay
uh what does he have to say about space
well here's this space is created by the
negative electric vortex
uh wave motions of negatively unwound
electrically simulated light space does
not contain matter
space is the inversion of matter and
matter is unfolded space okay so i guess
that's a matter of space turned around
the two give to each other endlessly
via rhythmic balance interchange of in
unwinding and unwinding twin opposing
electrical vortices which emanate from
motionless blah blah blah blah blah
okay so uh yeah uh these are the kinds
of things you're going to find in his
website okay now i do have to mention
that he mentioned me because at one time
he uh because you know uh i attacked the
establishment
he thought i thought like he did and so
he does mention him me and one of his
articles okay he might pull it down for
all i know later on but the point is
that he does mention me in there and i
don't want you to confuse him with me
and say oh uh
bill is a follower or sympathizes with
him no not at all not at all so if you
see that article there it's got nothing
you know he just pulled it out and
because he's got this notion that you
have the mortises that's the only reason
he put my name in there
anyways um
for a while he ran around with another
fellow uh by the name of matt presti
okay they formed some kind of
partnership
someone told me that it was a little
more than a partnership okay uh i guess
uh
you know
they like to see themselves as cowboys
so maybe
brings to mind you know the brokeback
type you know midnight cowboys
and they did a lot of numbers they
they're fanatic about all these weird
numbers uh this the thousands i'm sorry
the 1.618 uh ratio the golden ratio you
know and judging by what this guy told
me you know i think they didn't do many
threes they did more like six and nine
you know
but the point is that uh
later on they divorced i guess you know
um they had a separation of falling out
and presti went back east to virginia
and now he handles russell resilient
science you couldn't call it science in
the east in virginia and you can look up
his uh site
uh he's a russellian he's a he vouches
for
walter russell he's got a museum on
walter russell over there and you have
this other fellow
who
is in the west in california and he
handles russell over there okay
but
my bottom line is uh you know
i don't want
this follow
um interfering with communication
between people who come to the site
you know i'm uh i'm quite liberal i
allow people to do to post anything they
want
but uh bobby boy
don't please behave okay
do not interrupt communication among
people especially
in real time okay that's not good okay
uh
just you know work in your little hut
send the pipe bombs out but don't mess
around with communication okay
not good not good at all
anyways this is uh what uh you'll find
in presti's site over there in the east
okay russellian
so-called science these are some of the
titles you'll find there some are poe
poems others are um
presentations articles a little bit of
everything here you see some of the
names okay so if you're into the divine
whatever
uh well then uh go back east and see mr
matt presley and
he'll introduce you to i guess god right
god will work with you but not for it
okay
and yes all these uh spiritualists who
bring uh all this stuff into science
and uh then they get angry at the world
because the world doesn't pay attention
to them they say you're crazy
that's what they tell them in their face
and they don't like that and uh yeah
that's how the world runs
okay we have another fella and um
he uh he's a flat earther
okay
and what are the uh flat earthers well
you have a lot of sex a lot of religions
within the
uh religion known as
flat earth okay some some are fanatics
about you know they're moonies and uh
munis are people who don't believe we
went to the moon okay so a lot i think
all flat earthers are moonies okay but
some of them try to explain gravity um
using um
for example we covered this the other
day buoyancy um
inertia
um density they use these words others
talk about electricity causing you know
they're like the electric universe
so they like that aspect of it and they
have all these different sets within uh
platter okay
and this fellow is a fellow who it talks
about the ether okay he he's the guy who
proposes the eternity he created a uh
made a video about a week ago and so on
and uh someone referred him to me and so
i thought i'd analyze what this fellow
had to say about the ether because we
were talking about the ether
and his name is austin
and i don't know his last name but it
sounds something like nitwit it reminded
me of john cleese and faulty towers
uh
trying to educate manuel
okay so uh yeah uh especially after
reading his site that's or listening to
his video
uh
yeah
not not very uh positive
and what he had to say because he
believes that with ether he can explain
everything okay
and so this is what he says in general
okay this is out of his uh video ether
is a proposed logical foundation of
interpretation
okay
it is a philosophical framework
philosophical i'm wondering what this
has to do with physics okay
and a lot of people may not fully grasp
this yeah i'm one of those
i don't want to grasp it at all i mean
what's it got to do philosophy
it's a framework to explain a lot of
physical phenomena
okay so so this fella is talking about
philosophy that he thinks is philosophy
okay
and he's gonna bring this into physics
okay he says it's a
framework of philosophy and he's going
to be explaining something
in physics i guess gravity uh
magnetism all that stuff right
so maybe people don't fully realize that
it's a framework of interpretation
yeah i don't so far i can't follow you
you know because uh
philosophy has nothing at all to do with
physics okay
so it is logic uh
maybe
i don't know what kind of logic he has
it is a logical framework so by
definition it is philosophy
well that's strange that he would say
that because here we have
what philosophy is okay and stanford
encyclopedia philosophy
it doesn't define the term at all you
won't find the word philosophy defined
in the stanford encyclopedia of
philosophy
now that's a big
absentee there right
big uh
no show
i mean if you don't define philosophy
what is your site about what is the
stanford encyclopedia of philosophy if
we don't know what philosophy is
according to
the stanford encyclopedia philosophy
but then you look up the words elsewhere
and you find the study of fundamental
nature of knowledge reality and
existence
now existence has nothing to do with
philosophy the word exists the word
existence belongs exclusively
to physics
physics is the science of existence
anyone talking about existence whether
it's about god or the table or
the klingons on the other side of the
universe he has crossed the line whether
he knows it or not into physics
okay so it has nothing to do with
philosophy okay or same with reality
reality is a synonym of existence so uh
all he said is existence existence twice
and
um
no
philosophy has nothing to do with
knowledge okay
knowledge is a branch of religion okay
in physics and science we do not know
and
philosophy is one of the two branches of
science one is physics the other one is
philosophy another definition activity
people undertake when they seek to
understand fundamental truths
truth truth is an opinion
about themselves the world in which they
live and their relationship to the world
um
i don't think that has anything to do
with philosophy at all for that you need
to define philosophy and uh the
wikipedia says the systematized study of
general and fundamental questions such
as those about existence reason
knowledge same thing as the others
no philosophy has nothing to do with
that definition of philosophy you see it
down there rational explanations of
purposes and reasons
and it is chopped there anything that's
not within that definition does not
belong to philosophy okay
so all these people in the past uh like
um aristotle uh plato
hume david hume uh emmanuel kant
ayn rand wittgenstein russell
bertrand russell right
starter
none of those were philosophers
none of those were philosophers okay now
you might say bill but you're going
against the grain everybody says these
calls these people philosophers
well before you can call them
philosophers you need to define the word
philosophy
okay
and when you define it as
you know these sources have defined it
well you cannot place your finger on
what philosophy is if philosophy is just
a way of thinking then everybody's a
philosopher we got 8 billion
philosophers on the planet and we can't
distinguish you from plato
you're all philosophers
now we have to
define the word philosophy so we know
what we're talking about what the
discipline is about
and there you have a definition you
don't like it no problem
uh produce your own mousetrap make a
better mousetrap that's the only
recourse you have you have to define
philosophy in a way that we can use it
consistently scientifically okay
and so there you have it uh science is
rational explanations and philosophy is
the branch that studies purposes and
reasons
philosophy only deals with behavior so
you know historian might tell you why
someone went to uh
like why napoleon went to waterloo
that's a behavior that's a purpose a
reason that's philosophy
and a psychologist or psychiatrist might
tell you why you'd be
behave this way or or whatever and
that's also a philosopher okay that's
where philosophy is limited to that
behaviors
okay he says ether is postulated to be
an energetic metaphysical background
whatever that is what is energy
there is no physical object called
energy and he says it's metaphysical
whatever that means you know what what
are you talking about you're talking
about transcendental something that's
you know
not even beyond the mind i mean
what is this what is this energetic
metaphysical
and again they use all these
uh
aesthetic words or transcendental words
words of um
of spiritualism
and they think they're making sense okay
that acts as a medium
medium
uh he's saying that he's got this energy
energetic metaphysical abstraction i
guess that's what he means and then he
calls it a medium
or he wants to treat it as a medium
medium is very simple in physics medium
is that which has shape
that's a medium okay
so either it has shape or it don't
so if god wants to be
an object he has to have shape
and if god don't have shape because god
is spirit god is love got his
intelligence then god ain't
an object a medium a thing
that's how simple it is and if he ain't
a thing uh he doesn't exist by
definition because exists is a thing
that has location
we're done that's how simple it is if it
don't have location that doesn't exist
if it's not an object it can't even
begin to exist it's a concept there's
only concepts and objects period there's
no other category
okay so uh either uh
ether is a medium or it ain't it can't
be both okay either it has shape or it
don't
okay more specifically it is pure
potential
well potential doesn't like sound like a
medium potential sounds like a
mathematical word that we should never
use in physics or in science for that
matter what is potential what's that got
to do with science or physics
so if ether is a potential whatever that
is he talking about a mathematical
abstraction
that's how simple it is straightforward
so we're not talking about a thing
okay
and what's so important about that is
later on he's going to have these
non-things interact with things that's
where the problem is going to be so keep
that in mind okay put another way it is
what comprises all fills so he's going
to fill in the voids with this thing he
calls ether so here you have an object
you know i mean a ball okay you have a
ball
i guess the
uh
you know the vortices or the the um
the spaces in between are filled with
this so-called ether in other words he's
saying that ether is space what we call
space and physics which means it's
nothing
okay because that's what space is
nothing that which has no shape that's
what space is
object that which has shape space that
which does it that's how simple it is we
got
uh these two words which are antonyms
okay object and space
something and nothing
that simple that's how simple it is uh
it ether is an energetic metaphysical
background that acts as a medium
or substrate that sustains
electromagnetic phenomena
okay so he's going to treat it as a
medium and he's also going to treat it
as a non-thing he wants it as both
that's where the problem starts
so we have uh
the ethers both it's something and
nothing at the same time he covered both
bases he covered all bases
so um yeah with that you can do all
kinds of things you know when you bring
this spirit
that you can treat as a thing and at the
same time it's a nothing because that
ain't there
so it's something in
it is and it ain't
great so how do you make sense of
something like that you have a
contradiction built in there
okay and so um so he does realize that
he says that is the critique that
people make out there against the ether
and listen to him here it is again he
says what other critiques is the use of
the word medium here medium being
defined as some type of substance or
material
exactly
uh not well not exactly but uh medium um
object is that which has shape not all
shapes not all objects right are
substances or are material they're
substances because substance is a
synonym of object of thing but material
is not
okay material usually refers to
objects that exist matter matter is
objects that exist in other words
existence
whereas substance does not substance can
be
uh
something uh abstract okay we could call
it a substance uh for sure you can have
you know squares
uh squares don't exist and squares are
things
um
objects
you can call them substance if
you know you can use it as a synonym you
can use the word body structure any of
those to refer to a square because
square has shape
but a square is not material
okay so we just want to make that
difference here something immaterial
can't be called a medium
okay an immaterial medium is an oxymoron
right on but this is the criticism
that's lodged against
the ether is or the people who believe
in ether
or propose ether
if you take if you invoke a materialist
definition meaning there's nothing
outside the material world
physics
well we can't talk about anything
metaphysical effectively
yeah no kidding because the word
abstract which i guess that's what he's
referring to with metaphysical beyond
physics as aristotle
called his metaphysics right
um
when you're talking about
metaphysical you're talking about
abstractions something which is abstract
okay and it turns out that abstract is
the opposite of physical
physics deals with the physical
not with the abstract
okay
and so um
so he's got a contradiction because he's
going to say that you can't talk about
the metaphysical
if you're going to talk about the
material world meaning the world of
physics the physical world yeah no kid
there's a contradiction there and he
said terrible semantical arguments
okay and
yeah uh
one fellow in fact uh doubles up on that
on the immaterial stuff and he says the
following he says of course we do
experiments in science okay he talks
about experiments listen to this as for
the ether who cares about the name ether
is invisible learn fluid dynamics okay
i don't know about fluid dynamics but if
the ether is invisible and of course
they say it's immaterially intangible
right
what experiments are you going to be
doing to detect the ether okay
so he's got a little contradiction there
because we have an invisible and
intangible immaterial medium
right
which on
which they say look you cannot uh reach
with to it you can't reach it with an
experiment right because you can't see
or touch it
so we've got a contradiction he says we
have to do experiments but we're going
to detect this ether i guess
which is invisible and intangible
and
and yeah as you can see at the end the
spell says terrible semantic argument
semantical argument and yeah this is
this is what these people uh always uh
bring up okay let me move it over here
and uh so what do they say they always
accuse me of doing semantics okay they
say well you're doing semantics uh
when you define words when you uh you
know uh harp so much on language on
grammar
on definitions
they don't like it because it destroys
their religion and yeah uh let me put it
nicely science is a hundred and fifty
percent semantics
okay
if you don't tell me what your words
mean
specifically you know before you give
your presentation if you just start
ranting oh the ether it's a metaphysical
whatever
and it's a medium but it's an abstract
medium you can't see or touch it
it's an immaterial medium and all this
stuff well yeah you've got so much
contradictions that we have to stop you
before you continue
you can't continue giving your
presentation because we haven't
understood your foundation yet
so you got to identify the ether first
and if you're going to treat it as a
medium and you're going to say like this
fella's going to say in a minute that it
interfaces it and
you know
interacts
with
matter and we've got a serious problem
here because we've got this abstraction
that's not an entity this concept
it's gonna start banging against matter
that's what this guy's gonna argue
that's why you know what he proposes is
absolute nonsense okay
okay so here uh you can see he says
it acts as a medium
it is what sustains or carries carries
you know like on your back carries
electromagnetic energy
how do you carry energy i mean you grab
it with a spoon and uh and you know just
take it over like that you know
how do you carry energy
and so they use this language they say
oh you're playing semantics bill
yeah they don't know how to talk that's
why i do semantics because they they
have all these garbage words that were
shoved up their nose holes
in high school by the mathematicians who
created them and they don't even realize
these are mathematical words that
they're words that only relate to
mathematical physics which has nothing
to do with science
okay mathematical physics is an attempt
by the mathematicians to bring their
equations over into physics and try to
tell us that they can understand meaning
that they can explain right the
mechanisms that mother nature father
universe god the devil whoever you pray
to
use to run the world every day
and all they're doing is descriptions
and because they cannot explain they've
invented all these words such as energy
and inner shine whatever
they even created ether the word ether
okay it says there is no intertwined uh
metaphysical interaction between the
metaphysical and the physical world
there is an i'm sorry there is n
uh
if there is an interaction if they're
intertwined with a physical world how do
you have a concept such as ether
which is what he defined it as he's
saying it's immaterial it's not there at
all but it interfaces and interacts this
concept with your hand
with a table with a rock with a tree
with your house
we have a problem because there's a
terrible contradiction here how do you
have uh the word love or the word
intelligence or any other concept you
can imagine how about energy now there's
a word uh or the word field how do they
interact with matter if they're concepts
how do you have an uh concept such as
force
interact with my hand
you know i can have uh another hand
interact with my hand but not the word
force
the word force cannot touch my hand
because the word force is a concept and
this is what this fellow is doing he's
saying either is a concept it's an
abstraction it's wet metaphysical it
ain't an an object it
isn't a thing
and it's going to hit my hand
yeah it interfaces it's intertwined
and says you can be semantical with
everything
again these people accuse
people being semantics if i see it here
uh no i don't have it anyways uh and so
so they always say you're doing
semantics
you know and and we don't do so man we
came here to do physics and when they do
physics they they have abstract concepts
interfacing interacting with objects
if you can find all your
definitions to materialism it's stupid
well he hasn't explained why it's stupid
okay because physics is only
materialistic
you have to have objects you can't do
physics without an object you can't do
action at a distance action at a
distance is known as black magic
okay
because you haven't understood the
mechanism and you're assuming
that mother nature does these things
with concepts that man invented not even
man it's the
mathematicians that those are who
invented those concepts
ether acts as a medium in which the
phenomena light electrical actions at a
distance and propagation takes place
yeah again um you have to explain that
otherwise that's black magic to say
action at a distance and ether is
immaterial thus intrinsically cannot be
science
there we agree
yeah we agree cannot be science uh
whatever you're doing uh forget it
okay our fellow does
uh have you know a little hole in his
understanding of really because he
wasn't exposed to this site and so he
this is what he puts for the atoms
through the ages okay so he's got all
these atoms okay from john dalton uh
thompson's uh plum pudding
model there uh brother ford's uh proton
bores uh electron bead going around
right and schrodinger's uh
uh what is it uh the cloud model okay
the schrodinger and bourne model there
but what this was not aware of is my
model and that's this one okay
the bill gatey model and we have a
totally different model of the atom than
all these bozos from quantum mechanics
who had no idea whatsoever about physics
all they did was math okay so we have a
different atom
with this atom we can explain quantum
jump we can explain light light is the
torsion along the rope that
interconnects any two atoms in the
universe all atoms are physically not
abstractly or metaphysically they're
physically interconnected by a
uh very thin
right extremely thin
uh what we call electromagnetic rope
okay it's a rope-like structure we use
the word rope only because it has that
um architecture and only because of that
that's the only similarity between a
rope that you buy at the hardware store
and what you see there
and light is a torsion along the rope
torsion is the fastest
wave you want to call it that uh known
to light because it goes nowhere
essentially it um
torsion
in the case of a rope it twirls in situ
in place right and the signal is what
appears at the other end
and you can do this at home you can take
a rope you know and uh just tie it to
the wall or just something and as soon
as you torque it you'll see that there's
a thump on that object that is at the
other end okay so torch is the fastest
thing known to man
it's faster than uh
longitudinal wave which is faster than a
transverse wave okay and so our model is
uh more or less like this this is the
construction of our atom okay
and here you see it give it a second
here and it'll start again but
essentially all atoms in the universe
are connected to all other atoms okay
and what you have is there's the atom up
close
and here's how it's built how it's
constructed you have the electric thread
goes through the center of the atom
forms what is going to know what we are
going to know as the proton star it's
going to be a star-like
entity in the center okay and coming
around is the another thread which
arbitrarily we call it the magnetic
thread and that forms the electron shell
a membrane that encapsulates the proton
star
and all those ropes are connected to
every atom in the universe you can see
the ropes there converging upon the edge
of the electron shell okay
so you can see it there this is our atom
it's a different atom than uh
then what the quantum mechanics
came up with that atom expands in
contact
the electron shell it expands and
contracts and that's going to be the
quantum jump okay
so uh yeah we do have a different kind
of atom and based on that atom we can
explain light gravity
magnetism electricity and also you know
the workings of the atom in general okay
so yeah we have a different atom okay
and uh
what is the ether according to us well
it's a bunch of particles
and what these people have done all
these years is just wave it around
and uh they don't wave the whole ether
see when when you when you say i'm gonna
wave the tree
you don't wave a branch you wave the
whole tree if you're gonna wave the
branch you say i'm gonna wave the branch
but what these people say is the ether
is all over the universe
and you say well what is light and they
say it's the waving of the ether
so are they saying the whole ether waves
up and down
the whole thing as a single block
as a single uh fluid entity is that what
they're saying no they're saying that
what vibrates is a little tiny piece of
that ether
a little region and that's what they're
going to call light
okay so
so at least that's what it was until the
19th century okay and so here it is
that's the ether okay it's a bunch of
particles
that form like a backdrop and they are
particles because it they call it a
fluid and if it's a fluid hopefully a
fluid is made of parts
and so if it's made of parts this is how
they all envisioned it in the past in
fact i touched upon that the other day
where i told uh
what all these uh folks in the old days
and especially in the 17th century they
were the ones who resuscitated the ether
essentially from uh what the greeks had
done first one was descartes
descartes and he came up and he
proposed the ether again it was also
proposed by everyone in the 17th century
all the way to the 19th century
newton believed in the ether uh huggins
um
all of them you know they all believed
in the ether and they thought it was the
waving of the ether that that was light
and what was the either a bunch of park
and that's what it always was that's
always what it has been and what the
mechanics you know quantum mechanics did
and what the relativists did they went
in there and they changed the names
that's all they did the mechanics call
it the false vacuum and relativists call
it space time
so all they did was change the names i
mean what is space time made out of it's
made out of events what is an event a
point in space time
so we have all these little tiny little
points that make up space time and that
whole thing sounds like a sandbox
sandbox is what the ether is a bunch of
particles
and the
uh mechanics they say yeah when it
vibrates we have a wave and that wave is
what the
what light is
a transverse wave yeah
so yeah uh ether forget about it uh
until someone can define you have two
choices you either define the ether and
tell me what it what you mean by the
word ether hopefully you cannot define
it because if you define it it's a
concept
okay can't be an object can't be a thing
it's a concept so concepts we define
objects we point to
you have to show me an image and say
that's a rock that's a tree
that's a house
that's ether
that's how it works
and we want to see the whole shemane
okay so we have to see the whole shebang
okay you have to show me all of the
ether the shape of the ether
okay you can't say well it's infinite
and
it doesn't work there's no infinite
object objects are all finite so you get
a point and say ether and if you can't
do that you can't draw it you can't make
an image of the ether
you say no i'm going to define it fine
then it's a concept
okay you don't define god
god you either point you if he's an
object if it is an object if god is an
object or
you define god if god is love got his
intelligence and defined those words and
in which case he's not an object
you can't have both ways god cannot be a
concept and also an object either god
has shape or he don't that's how simple
it is
and the same with an ether either it has
shape or it doesn't
okay very simple
okay um uh so
let's get on with the subject matter of
today and what is the subject matter
today well it's uh
definitions okay do we need definitions
well yeah i think we do but some people
don't believe in definitions and they
think that when you define words
you are doing semantics
and that's what they say they say you're
doing semantics bill
they don't like definitions because it
destroys their religions okay so we have
all these flat universes flat earthers
and electric universes all these
flatlanders
and they all believe
in uh not defining words they don't they
don't accept the definition of words
why because it destroys their religion
and so they accuse you of doing
semantics and yeah science is 150
percent semantics you had better define
your terms before you start your
presentation so you know what you're
talking about okay
okay so uh one fella he goes in there
and he defines one word intangible okay
he says intangible unable to be touched
or grasped and having physical presence
well uh you know here we see how
definitions are important because either
intangible means unable to be touched or
it is physical presence those two are
not synonyms those two are not
the same okay
and uh so if you look up physical it
says relating to things perceived
through the senses as opposed to the
mind
tangible or concrete
so uh yeah if if you have the wrong
definition an irrational definition of
the word physical and then you put it
into the word intangible and say look
it's that which has physical presence
then we have a problem
okay because that's not what tangibility
means or intangible means okay
and so the fellow continues says
oxymoron a figure of speech in which
apparently contradictory terms appear in
conjunction and so he says intangible
physical is an oxymoron
yeah because he defined physical as that
which you can touch see you know using
the senses
that's where the problem is okay and
that's not what physical means because
physical is a synonym of object of thing
and it's not that which you can see
touch smell
taste here
an object is that which has shape all
the others require a second object first
of all and second requires a test you
need to smell it you need to touch it
you need to see it okay so we need two
objects according to them to define
object and then
you need an interview you need an
experiment and so we won't know until
you finish your experiment
you know here you have the
table on the other side of the universe
it's in the uh
in the uh klingons living room
and the table is not an object
it's not an object because i can't see
it i can't touch it smell it hear it
taste it
and
so it's not an object until i do
and some people say well
it is amenable
you can
touch it
it doesn't mean you have to touch it
means you can touch it well we won't
know until i touch it will be until i
run the experiment and touch it
so and besides i need another object
which is me
to touch it
you know the asteroid is not an object
the moon is not an object until the
asteroid hits the moon then they both
become objects suddenly until then and
they haven't touched each other so
they're not objects
and the blind man can't see the moon or
or the asteroid and so he says neither
one is it i can't see it
so yeah we have a rational definition
the c touch
criteria
are uh irrational
okay so if we start on the wrong side
you know of course everything's wrong
here's the word physical into wikipedia
again
uh dictionary
dot com says of or relating to the body
yeah
physical and body are
synonyms yeah of or relating to that
which is material okay the physical
universe okay not necessarily so not
exactly but close noting or pertaining
to the properties of matter and energy
hopefully nothing to energy because
energy has nothing to do with physical
energy as a concept
belongs to religion
because there's
500 types of energies out there you know
potential energy uh
kinetic energy they have so many
energies out there that you know and now
uh putin is shutting down the energy so
we won't have energy here in germany
so we'll find out what energy is i guess
uh the absence of at least uh tending to
touch hug pat no no uh physical isn't
has nothing to do with touch okay
uh but we use these words of ordinary
speech we bring them into physics we say
i found him in the dictionary
uh
bad way of doing physics okay now in
physics we have to define the terms and
if the word in the dictionary is
irrational we throw it in the garbage
scan the whole dictionary
okay
no we have to redefine the word if it's
broken we fix it
okay and so if the word physical is
broken we have to fix it
physical in wikipedia physical object or
physical body yeah
uh is a collection of matter
where they define
yeah no it's not a collection of matter
collection is mereology okay myriology
is religion has nothing to do with
science meteorology is what something is
made of
we don't care what something is made of
uh when we talk about an object a thing
a
physical entity we point and we say
that's a tree it's a physical thing okay
that's the way it works we don't say
well what is it made out of what is the
table made of well it's made out of
atoms first of all it's made out of wood
wood is made out of molecules molecules
out of atoms etcetera etcetera you know
electrons uh whatever
so we don't do any of that that's
meteorology that's uh religion we don't
use that what something is made out of
um
and so we call it the fallacy of
tangibility
physical has nothing to do with the
census
okay so we're so used to thinking of
physical of object of thing as something
that you can see or touch we equate that
word the word physical or the word
object thing with the word exist
because people think that exists is that
which you can see your touch an object
is that which you can see your touch
therefore the two words are synonyms as
mr david hume and mr emmanuel kant said
in the uh 18th century they said
we don't know what the word
exists adds to the word object to the
thing
and yeah what it adds is location that's
what it adds mr hume mr kant okay
anyways physical is not equal to the
senses okay we don't use the senses to
determine something that is physical not
in physics in ordinary speech that's
different that's religion okay
in physics uh it's that which has shape
and so tangibility visibility of all
facto
olfactable uh audible testable uh
tasteable none of those have anything to
do
with the word physical okay and that's
where the problem is physical that which
has shape we don't use the senses do we
can we see touch or smell or anything
the klingons table on the other side of
the universe absolutely not can we well
we don't know until we run the test
anyways you need two objects to do touch
so hopefully that's a bad criteria to
begin with and to do c as well
okay so yeah they say well you know what
do you mean by shape
you know these flatlanders they they say
oh i got you bill i can play that game
too i could play semantics too what do
you mean by shape oh my god that's how
they come up again so they say that
which has shape that's an object a thing
you know and they say well so what do
you mean by shape well the first
question why don't you ask what do you
mean by that
what do you mean by which
what do you mean by has i mean are those
words easier to define than shape
why did you ask about shape
i just thought you know i mean
they come at you like they know
something they're so smart you know they
say oh what do you mean by shape bill
well there here's your answer okay
uh so the issue here is how do we define
the word thing
for the purposes of physics that's what
it's all about and we either define them
as c touch which is what the
mathematicians have today what they use
today because they got it out of the
dictionary
dictionary that they did not write
the dictionaries were right by
grammarians uh
english majors librarians maybe
these people who have no stake in
physics they put the words in the
dictionary and these people just go to
the dictionary and say oh let's see what
an object is that that which you can see
or touch
and they just say well
then i'll go with this word now if it's
broken you got to fix it we fixed it
that which has shape okay so you have
the idiots of math and they use all
these words like c touch uh to define
object they use experiments they say
we're going to see and touch and so
we're going to go to the lab
and so uh you know here you have it uh
magnet okay there's two uh dark things
there so can you see or touch what's in
between the so-called magnetic field
that concept can you see or touch it
and uh here's another experiment here's
the spoon okay i'm gonna let go of it
and it always falls to the floor
uh let's make it scientific let's make
it repeatable okay we let it go to the
floor i didn't drop it it just fell from
my hands always falls to the blower try
it at home you don't believe me always
in the presence of a relativist okay
yeah when you do that you find that
always falls to the floor well can you
see or touch anything above or below
other than the air
and the answer is no
so uh what experiment you're going to
run to detect
how mother nature or what mother nature
uses to do gravity or magnetism
if you can't see or touch it
you can't smell it either it can't um
taste it can't hear it
so uh yeah
we don't we
have no idea what's in there and if you
have no idea what's in there you're not
going to determine it through an
experiment you can only visualize it
you can think about it you can try to
imagine what could mother nature be
using to do gravity what it what could
mother nature be using to do magnetism
then you can try to try to explain the
mechanism how that thing works okay but
you got to make it visible so that
you know you can visualize it for
someone else so that someone can see
okay i see what you get in your mind how
you visualize that magnet doesn't work
or how you visualize that gravity works
but these people say we're going to run
an experiment we're going to go to the
lab what are you going to go to the lab
for we did all the experiments we ever
did
needed to
determine gravity in other words to
understand
uh
what happens during gravity the the
the description of what we call gravity
gravity is this like blow this and fall
to the floor that's you the only
experiment you'll ever need
now explain it
how did that happen what caused it to
fall to the floor and not to the ceiling
that's what you got to do that's a
physicist okay
and we don't do equations but that's
what the mathematicians do they present
evidence evidence for what whatever it
is you're going to present for gravity
for the cause the mechanism of gravity
then they try to talk about proof and
that they have knowledge that they have
accumulated
well when you know something
you know you have religion because that
means you already know it
so there's nothing that anybody can do
to change your mind because you know it
and so knowledge is individual and
knowledge means that you already know it
and when you know something you know god
nobody's going to take god away from you
okay so you know god exists god is there
i saw god he talked to me okay so
what can we say you know it
and what they do is you know they move
concepts around they persuade they win
prizes none of that is what we do in
science okay the scientists does all the
other things on the right there okay
and yeah you can't uh
uh you have if you're going to define
the word object the word thing for the
purposes of physics you need to
determine whether you're going to use
the c touch criteria which mathematics
uh mathematicians use or you're going to
use the one we propose here which is
that which has shape okay so this is not
a question of saying what do you mean by
shape
well what happened did you miss
kindergarten or something i mean you
don't know what shape is go to a
kindergarten you know with a cube and a
sphere
same material same color same everything
except
you know the difference between a cube
and a sphere if you know what the
difference is maybe a flat lender
wouldn't know but
i mean a normal person would know and
you go to kindergarten and you say well
kids
what's the difference between these two
they see the color the same the volume
is the same everything's the same
if you think
and continue with kevin they would
educate you they would tell you that the
difference is the shape that's what
shape is that's all you need to know
what we need to determine is the
difference between mathematics and
science and mathematicians use the
criteria of c touch
which is irrational
and what we use here what we propose is
that which has shape
then you can use the word consistently
ever there's no object in the universe
that you can even imagine that doesn't
have shape it's the universal property
all objects happen on the other hand see
touch well we can't see all objects can
we we can't see gravity right whatever
causes gravity
whether it's the particles that push or
the ropes that are pulling right
uh you know we can't see the mediator of
gravity so not all objects can be seen
not all objects can be touched
and and so it's an irrational definition
the one that people have out there 99 of
humanity spiritualist right
they believe in c touch they they want
to prove they want to sense they want to
run an experiment
okay so um physics what is that rational
explanations of causes and mechanisms
foundations of physics include those
words you must define these words if you
want to do physics you cannot elude
defining them you need to define the
first word of physics object you need to
define what an object is because physics
cannot be done without an object
okay you can't do physics unless there
are objects out there so the first word
physicist has to define is the word
object then we have to have distance we
need to know what's distance is
separation between two objects location
the set of distances
motion two or more locations exist
an object that has location
concept a word that invokes or embodies
two objects
okay so we need two objects because a
concept is a relation a contrast a
uh
a uh
essentially a relation between two
objects and you have to have
a
recorder
a human
to uh conceptualize you can't do it
without having a mind okay mother nature
she doesn't understand she only works
with objects she doesn't understand
concepts all concepts were invented by
man especially mathematical concepts
relations you know ratios and so on
anyways and space that which doesn't
have shape
the definition of the word object
destroys all religions once you define
the word object
people have to choose whether their god
is an object or a concept
and i put that question to a bunch of uh
palestinians who were in
scotland with me
giving a presentation at a university
over there in saint andrews
and i put that question to them they
were all muslims and i asked them
whether their god allah
was an object or a concept
well one guy said well it's neither
another guy said it's both
he's both and the third guy said well if
i knew
whether god was an object or concept or
what he looks like then god wouldn't be
that great would he
those are the kind of answers you're
going to get
okay so here we continue paul says an
object can have internal motion yet no
external motion okay so he start
starting to talk about motions within
objects so he says look you have things
like clouds and fire and tornadoes
and
they're you know they already have in
body motion
they don't stand still you know they
from frame to frame in the movie they're
moving at least one atom moves in there
and it's not the same object as it was
before it wasn't the same shape
that's essentially his argument
and what can we say poor fellow you know
these perfect people and this is the
answer okay you must define the word
object before you define the word
distance location motion exists it's a
concept all those words are dependent on
the word object so you can't define you
can't talk about motion before you
define the word object so you can't say
well you know all objects have motion no
that's not true you know
not all objects can move okay and um
the fact that objects do move
you know from like you know
the defined motion you need to define it
as two or more locations the problem
there is that a square does not have
location to begin with and if a square
doesn't have location
it cannot have motion
you cannot conceptualize the motion of a
square except in a cartoon okay because
it's it's an object because it has shape
but it has no location nothing that has
or anything that has 2d
uh doesn't have location and so the
issue is that
not all objects move first of all but
that's irrelevant you have to define the
word object before you define the word
motion this guy's starting to introduce
the word motion in in the definition of
objects as the cloud moves it changes
its shape and so on i could take a
picture
of us a cloud
and assuming i had god's camera and i
have every atom in there right and i put
it in a snapshot in a in a one frame of
the film and in that frame of the film
that thing that seat that i see there is
called a cloud
and in there there's no in a photograph
there's no atom that is moving
it'll move in the next frame but not in
that frame okay
shape is a static concept okay so don't
talk about motion you know you're you're
you're spinning your wheels out there
another fella says the following says uh
solid is object heated solid turns to
liquid so it's object
heated liquid turns to gas so it's an
object but if you heat up a gas so it's
plasma then it isn't an object
because plasma is not an object plasma
is not a thing
plasma is a thing in
motion plasma is a word that embodies
motion just like the word energy
embodies motion you cannot take a
picture of energy of plasma
or a force
because these words already embody
motion it's like taking a picture of
running
if i take a picture of running i won't
get running i'll get a man you know
maybe with one leg in front of the other
he's solid he's
static in that picture
and you can't say he's running i don't
know if he's running
that's not running running i need two
frames because it's a verb i need two
frames at least in the universal movie
plasma requires two frames okay and
again what happens is these people are
introducing motion already and he's
saying uh a liquid is solid that is
heated no no that's how what a liquid is
i have water okay and i point to water
and water has shape there you see a
liquid we call it water okay that's not
supposed to be water and that's a
snapshot of water
okay does it have shape we're done
if it has shapens we're done
gas
we have a bundle of atoms
right we call it gas it's a blob of gas
the astronaut drew glass gas in space he
he popped the balloon with colored gas
he takes the snapshot of that gas as
it's expanding or sub you know blow
that blob is moving through
space here right so he takes a snapshot
of that colorful gas
can he do that yeah when he shows you
the picture that's gas what you see in
the picture he calls it gas
so gas is a physical object you say but
it's made out of adam well so it's the
table
you know just because the table doesn't
break apart it's not an object
again meteorology
meteorology is what something is made
out of that's not what an object is an
object is that thing i point to in a
picture in a static image
okay
you can't do that with plasma i take a
picture of plasma and i don't get plasma
okay why because
what's missing is the ionized part
you know the little electron leaving
you know moving
uh ex being
expelled from the atom
that motion i cannot synthesize it in a
photograph
okay and that's what the electric
universe is and people like this fellow
probably is one uh don't understand
plasma is not an object because we don't
heat up
solid to liquid to gas to plasma that's
how you determine what an object is the
way we determine is we say does it have
shape in a single frame of the movie and
you can do that with solid you can do
that with liquid and gas you can't do
that with plasma because plasma includes
the word ionized in it
ionize is a verb
something is happening
there's motion in there so it's a verb
for the purposes of physics okay
so
you know you might say motion is a noun
in ordinary speech not in science in
science the word motion is a verb you
can't say motion is a noun you can't
talk about motion motion is what
something
does
meaning verb motion
two or more locations another fella
along the same line says temperature is
a scalar field whatever field is what is
it like a poppy field maybe a football
field i mean i don't know is temperature
a concept and again these people have
never defined terms so they don't know
whether it's a concept or not very
simple define the word concept and
you'll find out whether temperature is a
concept you just have to define the word
concept okay
and uh yeah a concept a word that
invokes or embodies two objects
does temperature
involve two objects in any way shape or
form in the notion in the
concept we have of the word temperature
of course it does temperature hopefully
is a relation okay
and another foul says ropes are a
concept
rope is a concept he says okay
because it's just your theory
oh so anything that's my theory is just
a concept i guess
you were talking about gravity existing
in one of your previous videos as well
no hopefully not i never said that
gravity exists
so you heard wrong but you could you're
welcome to
unless it was a slip of the tongue but
never do i say that a concept exists
okay
concepts happen especially dynamic
concepts like gravity okay
electricity definitely exists no you
can't say that
electricity exists because electricity
is a moving thing
okay electricity according to the
official version right is a bunch of
electrons that are moving from atom to
atom it's a series of moving atoms so
you can't say electricity exists because
exists is object with location not with
motion
okay he says just try touching
electricity
so this poor fellow goes throughout his
outlets to find out every morning he
says let's see if electricity is an
object he sticks his fingers in there
and gets a zap and he says oh yeah
electricity is an object because it hit
my hand
it touched me
that's how he determines what all what
an object is in physics
fields exist okay yeah maybe i guess a
football field maybe how else would
motors generator transformers come
passes etc work uh if there weren't any
magnetic fields
yeah field is a concept concepts don't
exist in physics concepts exist in
ordinary speech because no one defined
the word exists in the last three
thousand years so people say oh love
exists
intelligence exists
no no first you've got to define and
exist then we'll know whether you know
love exists
and you can't use concepts with the word
exist in physics in science in ordinary
speech you can say whatever you want
okay you can say god exists if you want
no problem
but in physics you must define the word
exist object
that has location location is a static
concept so it's objects both of these
are static concepts right so uh to say
that a field exists is irrational
field cannot exist because field is a
bunch of numbers
and a bunch of numbers does not an
object make
okay
and you just made a video arguing
semantics yeah again all these people
say bill what you're doing is semante
stop doing semantics bill you're driving
us nuts with samantha no
physics is 150 semantics if you don't do
semantics you don't define your terms we
have no idea what you're saying we don't
know what's going through your tiny
little brain
okay so
please define your term before you talk
okay and so these are irrational
concepts that mathematicians treat as
objects move around and fed to you in
high school or maybe in
college
so if you use any of these words in any
way shape or form to and you introduce
them into physics you are an irrational
individual you are just a mathematician
you are or maybe uh you're just
parenting with the mathematicians um fed
you in high school or college that's all
you're doing so if you're doing physical
interpretations with any of these
concepts
okay then you got a problem
that means you don't understand the
basics of physics
that's where and so here we treat you as
an idiot what is an idiot a person with
big ideas
okay okay um
so here we have a definition of
definition what is a definition
scientific definition okay so limitation
placed on the extent or usage of a word
okay
i use a really a terrible example but i
think it drives home the point so i hope
you'll bear with me if you say it's
white and has wings
what are you talking about a swan or the
white house
and how are you gonna
zero in on which one i'm talking about
and you say well you know uh it's a
building well now you've limited you've
eliminated at least a bird
and that's more or less what a
definition is you put things in there so
you eliminate all other things you limit
the usage and extent of that word
okay
and so that is a scientific definition
okay
definition is not the same as meaning
people say oh it's the meaning of a word
absolutely not
definition is what a prosecutor proposes
meaning is what the juror gets out of it
okay one's on the
receiving end the other one's on the
emitting end okay so to speak meaning
has to do with how a definition is
interpreted how it's processed what
you're receiving that's meaning if a
definition is on the emitting end
meaning is on the receiving end a
prosecutor issues definitions a juror
infers
meaning
okay
and uh to close up here we have it
if you don't like my definition no
problem you can't use any of these
fallacies to counteract it you can't say
it's the fallacy of tradition
this definition has been used for
hundreds of years according to the
etymology now we don't care about where
it started or how badly our forefathers
define the terms okay so that's the
first one you gotta eliminate then you
have the fallacy of authority that's
what the dictionary says and what my
guru told me to memorize
not good not a good argument not at all
we have the fallacy of democracy
the hooded monks voted for my definition
well yeah uh
now we belong to a different club here
you know we don't we don't have these
hooded monks over here here you have to
defend your definition like you see down
there below you must defend your
definition in the coliseum with sword
and shield
okay
if you can't be uh
a critic alone you have to put something
in your chain you know you have the
critic who says oh the boxer should have
hit him with a right or with a left
yeah that's easy when you're the critic
down there in the audience
the scientist the definer the person who
defines he's got to be the boxer in the
ring he can't be the critic
so you got to be a little more than a
skeptic or a critic you got to get in
the ring propose a definition and defend
it
that's the way it works in science okay
and i know a lot of people don't like
that because they're not used to that
kind of thing and they don't want to get
into the ring they just want to from the
outside you know say oh let me tell you
what that you're wrong okay so i'm wrong
tell me what's right
that's the way it works in science
okay uh we have our science critic okay
and uh today he's gonna talk to us
about uh magnetic field again we talked
about a little bit about the magnetic
field a little while ago okay and this
file says that uh you know you have a
magnetic field
here we have you know magnetic field
and in this case it's attraction right
and there i have another magnet does
repulsion as well but the issue is
there's something invisible there
and we call that invisible region
a field man
came from michael faraday
they say that the earliest he wrote
about it 1845 i think he he already
talked about it before then maybe that's
the first time you wrote about it or
maybe he presented at the royal um
is it society
anyways the point here is that field is
a concept field means a bunch of numbers
that's what field is field is a bunch of
numbers that get weaker and weaker
values magnitudes that get weaker and
weaker and the farther you away you get
from ground zero okay so if you take
a gravitational field
what do you mean by gravitational field
well field
is a
is the center of gravity in this case
and from there the farther or farther
you away you get the weaker is the
gravity
and you can say the same thing about an
electric field and a magnetic field okay
so on
okay so what does this fellow say well
he raised several arguments here they go
so listen carefully here goes
the questions and issues to be addressed
in this rebuttal include
is action at a distance a rational
explanation for a physical mechanism
or black magic
does touch
mean that you are not actually touching
the thing
and is it possible to make a magnetic
field visible
the fifth video in the series is called
not so magical action at a distance and
it does remind me of the spooky action
at a distance so magnetism may look like
magic to some people but that's only
because it's difficult to imagine things
being able to interact if they're not
touching but the thing that we don't
realize is is that when we touch
something we're not actually physically
touching it this is because of repulsive
forces between atoms but the thing is
you cannot make the magnetic field
visible
okay so you said a mouthful there okay
uh several arguments let's go with one
of them here we go
this is what i've got to say about it
science really you can't touch the table
because of repulsive forces between
atoms
maybe he meant repulsive horses
maybe i
heard him wrong
there's no such thing as force
so to say you have a repulsive force
that prevents you from touching the
table you haven't said anything all
you're saying is intelligence is getting
between your fingers and the table
that's what you're saying you're saying
that is there's a concept called force
okay
i need to know what physical object is
preventing you from touching the table
and before you can use the word touch
you need to define the word touch what
do you mean by touch
and of course he never defined it he has
no idea what the word touch means he
just pairs with the mathematicians of
quantum mechanics the
uh these folks you know they fed them in
high school or college and they said
look you know you have two atoms you
have these forces that prevent two atoms
from coming together
what are they evil forces i mean what
kind of may the force go with you you
know
i mean what is this force
and they just use these concepts they
throw them in there and say there's a
force
that prevents you from touching the
table
yeah so you know again
totally irrationality and why is
irrational because they get used to the
language
and the mathematicians fed these this
language to them in college or high
school and they said look there's a
force
and the guy says oh
there's a force
okay and then here's the other issue and
let me turn this on because i did
make the field visible for him
but he says you can't make a field
visible
well how come i can
i mean i did and this is what i showed
them here it goes okay give me a second
here here goes listen carefully
is this really magical action at a
distance
what if we could make the invisible
mediators that mother nature uses to do
this trick
visible
if we could see that the magnetic field
holding the ball up consists of
countless threads swinging under it
the trick would no longer be so mystical
and incomprehensible
okay
so i hopefully you had eyes and you
could see
what was there you had
all these threads
and they're swinging around at great
speeds maybe at the speed of light
underneath the ball and that's what
keeps the ball up there otherwise you're
going to be doing
action at a distance
meaning
black magic
you're going to say that ball just
stands there with nothing underneath it
nothing above it i guess you know or
something pulling on it is that what
you're suggesting maybe that's what's
happening i don't know
i'm suggesting that underneath it you
have all these threads that are swinging
underneath it
these are untouchable unseeable threads
the threads that form the
electromagnetic road they're swinging
around hitting the bottom of the ball
and maintaining it up there that's what
they're doing so i made the magnetic
field
this concept that
faraday invented i'm making it visible
so that people understand the mechanism
i propose for how mother nature is doing
that magic trick
that's physics that's called physics
because i'm giving you an explanation of
the mechanism
you don't have to believe in it but now
you understand what's going through my
brain okay
you have a different theory tell me how
mother nature is doing that magic trick
make visible
the objects that are keeping that ball
up in the air
if you say it's a force it's a field
it's energy it's mass it's whatever time
then you're using concepts you're not
explaining any you're not giving me a
mechanism all you're doing is
giving me action at a distance which is
black
magic
okay let's go with some of the questions
some people ask here comments people
made one file says gravity is
technically not a force
okay your entire talk is a false premise
you cook
what's your shitty definition of gravity
you don't need ad hominem attacks to
present a better idea of gravity
i like the contradiction there yeah he
calls me a kook he says your shitty
definition but he says
why are you using all these ad hominem
attacks
and yeah i explained that the other day
i have no problem with people calling me
kook or whatever i hate the uh
you know as i found out naively on my
part you know when i when i presented my
theory out there that
uh
half the world laughs at the other half
and ridicules the other half of the
world and so you know um
when i went out there with my theory i
thought that you know people would say
oh that's an interesting thing here
that's a novel theory it's i'll i'll
ponder it oh let me consider it or maybe
they said no i don't like it okay fine
no problem that's not what i got
i was ridiculed i was laughed at they
threw tomatoes and
rotten eggs at me
that's how i was received
and that was a wake-up call i thought
that's not how science worked but that's
the scientific environment out there and
that's been the scientific environment
all the way to the days of the greek and
even before that
people had laughed at the other half the
muslim laughs at the buddhists the
buddhists laughs at the hindu the hindu
laughs that the christian and the
christian lamps at all of them and all
of them laugh at the christian
that's the world out there everybody
laughs at
other people they ridicule them
and they
belittle them and so on and that's the
world we have in science and i thought
science was different but it ain't
and so um you know you just have to
accept that that's how things are out
there and it
you know it adds insult to injury when
you want to publish a paper and you have
one of these people
who look at your paper and they're from
the club
and you're trying to go against the club
you know it's like you presenting a
paper an atheist paper at the vatican
and say
i want to publish this paper showing the
proving that god does not exist
what is the vatican going to do
you know they're probably going to throw
in the trash can clean their butts with
it
and that's exactly what you have out
there in the world of so-called science
so you know get used to it if you can't
you don't have a stomach for it don't
get involved in physics because
it's a doggy dog world out there cut
throat work
so
get get used to it if you're going to go
into physics
uh electricity is not an object okay
well thank god nor is it the flow of
electrons oh that's news okay what do
you propose accuracy is the distortion
of the medium
which makes motion imperative
well what medium i mean what do you mean
distortion and i mean what is he talking
about
and he says electricity is the cause
gravity is an effect
so far we have poetry great i mean you
know you can put some music behind this
if you want electricity is the plucking
of a guitar string gravity is the return
to stillness
okay so far we know nothing about
electricity or gravity for that matter
electricity is a distortion of an
equilibrium for you you upset the
equilibrium gravity is the return to
that equilibrium
so we have not learned anything about
electricity or gravity from this
gentleman okay so i'm sorry fella you
gotta work on it on your theory a little
more you know we we still have no idea
what you're talking about okay
okay
um
give me a second here
uh
there we go it is impossible to know
what causes gravity
it is
uh i don't know about impossible because
i
can tell you what causes gravity in fact
i have a theory out there i've got it
illustrated all you have to do is look
at the theory
you know
essentially watch a
video
and you'll learn what gravity is from my
point of view
now you may say well you don't agree you
don't like that theory okay that's fine
but i can give you a theory of gravity
a physical theory of gravity of how
this spoon falls to the floor okay what
causes it to fall the floor to the floor
and not to the ceiling for example okay
so yeah i do have a theory and so this
because it's impossible well you know i
mean corporal
gravity doesn't create energy energy
creates gravity
well if energy creates gravity we're
done right you know what gravity is it's
caused by energy
whatever energy is and again these
people use these words that the
mathematicians put in their heads and
they just repeat them they don't even
know what they're taught saying they say
oh energy like if we knew what energy is
and you have richard feynman nobel prize
1965 and he said oh by the way we have
no idea what energy is
yeah dickie because the problem is that
energy is not a what
so you can't say what is energy energy
is a concept it's an irrational concept
and it's got to do solely with
mathematics so as long as you keep it
within mathematics and use the
uh
magnitudes and the units
with it and you want to call that energy
no problem keep it there no problem when
you try to bring it into physics that's
when it becomes an irrational concept
okay because you're treating it as a
physical object and this guy just pulled
that and says oh energy is gravity it
causes gravity creates gravity well if
he's going to say that how can he say
that it's impossible to know what causes
gravity when he says energy creates
gravity looks like we know what causes
gravity right it's energy
um
at absolute zero there is no energy to
manipulate space
oh man he's going to manipulate space
nothing
he's going to handle it you know okay
how do you handle space how do you
handle nothing i mean i can handle
nothing every day i do nothing every day
so i guess it's easy to do nothing to
move nothing around
uh space itself is an extremely
pressurized absolute zero field
it's a pressurized all that pressure
from space you're just crushing us you
know
uh normal matter manipulates this field
so we have normal matter it manipulates
the field which is space
you know this is what these people have
in their tiny brains what is this
poor felder talking about he's got
birdies in his head
particles push out on the natural
pressure of space now i got to stop it
there because i mean this is absolute
nonsense
space is nothing
and space is a concept
concepts do not interface or touch or do
anything with matter
uh they don't have pressure so i don't
know what this pressure thingy is that
you're talking about
all i can say is you know you gotta find
out what space is first define it
we define it because we can't draw space
can't draw a picture so it's not an
object it's a concept and space is a
synonym of nothing nothing is defined as
that which doesn't have shape we're done
we have something which is an object and
nothing which is space we're done see
how easy it was
uh an object that which has shape
nothing in other words something is that
which has shape nothing is that which
doesn't have shape see how easy it was
they're antonyms
okay well it says energy creates gravity
absolute zero temperature
uh
at which a thermodynamic system has the
lowest energy there is still energy at
absolute zero he answered the previous
guy one guy says there's no energy at
absolute zero this guy says there is and
i'm saying man it can't be energy
because energy is a concept at any
temperature okay so whether it's
absolute zero or not there is no such
thing as energy so you can't say there
is energy there exists energy we find
energy we kick energy we touch energy at
absolute zero now you can never touch
concepts there is no such thing as
energy you can't talk about the
existence of energy find another word
okay
and it's not only the word it's the
concept the notion that these people
have
bell says mass is a scalar okay
mainstream physicists say that mass is
energy or more recently bonding energy
of gluons
bonding energy of gluons all these
gluons you know between quarks i guess
they're popping out of there you know
and creates all this mass
so he asks what is mass yeah good
question what is mass another foul says
along the same lines it says mass is
your weight on earth
your weight on the moon would be much
less but your mass remains the same am i
correct
uh or am i incorrect uh no you're
incorrect uh your mass remains exactly
the same on the moon because the way we
determine mass is by weight we put it on
a scale we weigh you we say that's your
mass
so until the mathematicians can
uh separate
you know isolate mass from weight and
weight from mass
we will never know what mass is because
mass is weight and weight is mass
and you say well that's on the earth on
the moon how about on the moon on the
moon we take you over there we weigh you
and say your mass is so many kilograms
and but that's not the way they define
it the way they define it is mass is the
quantity of matter or
a measure of the amount of matter
and the problem there is that they never
express that in terms of atoms or units
of mass they don't say look this has a
hundred units of mass whatever those
were okay or are right
so we define a unit of mass we can say
maybe it's number of hydrogen atoms one
hydrogen atom is one unit of mass great
so we say this has a mass of because one
gazillion one trillion uh
units of mass or hydrogen atoms
now if you express it like that you can
say okay one trillion atoms here on
earth is one trillion atoms also on the
moon
because you express it in number of
atoms or number of hydrogen or number of
units of mass no problem that's not the
way they ever
present mass they always say mass is the
quantity of matter or a measure of the
quantity of matter and then they're
going to give it to you in kilograms
which is not a quantity you know it's
not counting
number of atoms
number of hydrogen number of units of
matter it's measuring they say we weigh
it and we tell you how many kilograms it
weighs and that's mass
so yeah we'll never find out what the
difference between mass and weight is
because we determine mass by way
and we express
mass in terms of kilograms not in units
of matter
okay and then another vowel says gravity
is mass times acceleration i guess he
confused it with newton's second law
which is force equals times mass times
acceleration that force is not equal to
the uh gravitational so-called force
which is really tension
which is uh gravitational constant g
mass 1 mass 2 divided by distance square
that's the equation for gravity gravity
not uh this one which is
newton's second law okay
anyways it says mass is the coupling
effect of gluons another gluon guy mass
is created from the massless gluons
connected to quarks
how are they connected i mean
are they like bed springs that stretch
back and forth is that what you saw
maybe and confuse the i mean if you if
you think they're bed springs uh look it
up on the uh standard
uh model chart and see if you can find a
bed spring there for the word glue on
okay i want to see the bed spring i've
never seen a bed spring in there they
always show particles in fact they show
the letters this is the g for glue on
this is the q for quark that's what they
showed you
okay anyway so they says mass is created
from massless gluons and don't say the
gluon is has electrical magnetic force
because that would make it eu electric
universe
yeah again uh there are no such thing as
gluons okay
and you have to understand how they came
up with all this nonsense the quantum
guys and why they won all these nobel
prizes
it started in the 60s primarily between
people like feynman and
zwiki was one of them i think and so on
and all these people what they did
they went in there and said do we have a
um a good explanation
for why the neutron and has no
uh charge and the proton does have
charge
and so they say well if you have two up
quarks and one down quark which is the
proton and you have the neutron which is
two down quarks and one up quark
right
and uh
it will be great to show you a picture
which is worth a thousand words but the
point here is that if you add these
things up
you end up with
in the case of the neutron no charge in
the case of proton one charge
and that's just
a a mathematical trick that they created
to invent the quarks for the neutron and
for the uh for the proton okay so it's
just a mathematical contraption that
they came up with to explain why one has
charge and the other one doesn't they've
never seen a quark they've never seen a
proton they've never seen a hydrogen
atom which is bigger than a proton which
is bigger than a quark which is bigger
than a gluon
they've never saw any of these
so-called particles
and but they filled the standard model
chart so you know they have all these
things out there and they've never seen
or they never
you know
touched or
verified any of them
it's all theory
it's a theory it's an irrational theory
because it's all based on particles and
the problem with that is that you cannot
explain for example in the case of the
gluon how gloom which is tiny particles
supposedly right it's just another
particle another concept they call it
particle which is not really a core
puzzle but assuming that's what people
think when they uh
what they visualize when they when you
mention the word corpuscle or gluon or
particle
it's a particle that goes back and forth
or that's thrown by one quark against
another and somehow pulls them together
well try doing it at home you know take
a rock and throw it at your wife and see
if you attract her
and if she throws a dish at your head
and attracts you
maybe she does maybe your anger
makes you go to her the only way she can
attract you
okay so here's that bill says a
hypothesis is not a theory which he
thornhill thinks it is
aha meanwhile
uh on the screen is a quote from
thornhill saying a hypothesis is not a
theory until it's been tested
experimentally
you can't be caught much more red-handed
than that
well obviously this poor fellow doesn't
understand squat
no
he doesn't understand because he thinks
that a hypothesis is what the
mathematicians fed him in high school in
college that's not what a hypothesis is
and that's what walt
while you hear you know walter
he thinks a hypothesis is he thinks it's
a tentative guess or a tentative theory
that it doesn't become theory until you
run some kind of experiment and verify
it or or are more certain of of that
hunch
that not at all what we call a
hypothesis we raise all that completely
thrown in the garbage can that's not a
hypothesis hypothesis is the objects the
definitions and the statement of the
facts those are the hypotheses okay what
is a hypothesis it's an assumption but
people confuse the word assumption with
the word theory they say well i'm going
to make an assumption a guess
you know a hypothesis i'm going to
hypothesize
and so they think that a hypothesis is
that an assumption is some kind of
tentative explanation that's not what an
assumption is the assumption is laying
the groundwork on which you're going to
found you know you're going to base your
theory on these foundations
and for that you need first the object
you need to identify the objects you
need to have the definitions and then
you finally make a statement of the
facts not the facts only mother nature
god the devil you know father universe
those those folks they know the facts
they have a file cabinet with all the
facts of what actually happened we can
only
make a statement of the facts what you
what the prosecutor thinks are the facts
the defense attorney has a different set
of facts so you can only make a
statement of the facts those are the
hypotheses
and those are the
uh assumptions
now you're going to base your theory on
that set of assumptions
and that's not what wall or this fellow
thinks is a hypothesis they think a
hypothesis is a theory they have no
difference between a hypothesis and a
theory in both cases it's an explanation
one is a tentative one and the other one
is one that has a little more evidence
behind it that's what they have in their
tiny little brains okay that's why this
call didn't understand squat
okay uh quantum computers electricity
magnetism time what defines quantum
computing
and uh there you have an answer quantum
computers uh use effects
that quantum mechanics has yet to
explain such as entanglement
superposition and decoherence
so they have all these uh and there you
see a couple of those right uh you have
what is superposition you have the
coherence there
and they have these these things which
they explain right or better yet don't
explain with particles and they say okay
with particles we think that the two
particles are in the same place at the
same time one vibrates the other one
doesn't it can vibrate and not vibrate
at the same time
and it can be at two places at once
and they have created all these monsters
based on the particle hypothesis
they don't understand it they can't
explain it
but they they use the effect
they go to the lab they see an effect
and they use the effect it's like it's
like let's let's go with something
simpler
two magnets right
the the two circles there okay
now i can see that this magnet attracts
this one and you know i can measure how
how strong that does it and i get a
stronger magnet it does much better
and then at some point i say hey i can
use that
what can you use it for well i can go to
the
junkyard and i can use this big magnet
and pull cars out of there
so he uses the magnet
for technology
but he has no idea how how the magnet
does it he doesn't need to know how he
does it all he needs to know is that he
can use the effect
and as and that's what happened uh with
quantum computers they don't understand
the coherence they don't understand
superposition or entanglement they don't
understand any of that they don't they
cannot explain it but they realize
there's an effect there
they explain it quotations on that the
mechanism with particles they say we
don't understand we can't make sense of
it we don't care about that that's
philosophy but they use the effect and
they say oh we're going to call it a
quantum computer because we're using all
these effects in that computer
that's
why the word quantum the adjective
quantum comes in front of the computer
that's the only reason okay they don't
understand and you can call it the x
computer it doesn't matter anyways
because they cannot explain a magnetic
field let alone you know some of these
other phenomena such as entanglement and
decoherence
okay so here's another foul that says
what are the roast made out of oh that's
simple two threads i mean here here's a
rope
uh you don't believe me you don't
understand me go to the hardware store
and you'll see ask them for a rope a
two-strand rope and it looks something
like this it's on one strand
wound around another
so what is the rope made of two threads
two strands two wires two strings
whatever you want to call them
see how easy it was very simple another
foul says what element or elements is
the thread the intertwined ropes and
that
intertwined rugs and atoms in other
words uh he's saying you know here he
wants to know now what the thread
each one of these like the red one or
the blue one what is that one made out
of
well the answer is that it's a
fundamental entity see you can't
continue passing the buck at some point
the bug stops here
okay
and
like in the case of quantum mechanics
they say well what is that particle made
out of and they said we'll give us a
million dollars
we'll create this accelerator we'll
smash
particles whatever they are
together and whatever debris comes out
of there
we'll give them names this one's tommy
that one's johnny that one's peter
and so they get all these names and they
say give me my noble okay we give them a
noble and now they say okay what is
little uh johnny made out of they said
give us a billion dollars now we'll
build
a super collider as big as the solar
system
will smash all the johnnies all the
peters all the joeys you know
and
you know when they break apart they say
well that one's susie that one's sally
and so that's what they're made out of
now give me my novel and that's all they
do and they keep
bashing you know they keep smashing all
these particles and giving names to
whatever they breathe they think they
see in their uh
bubble chambers or whatever right
so
all they're doing is breaking apart
particles and someone asking what is
that one made out of well give me more
money i'll break it apart i'll tell you
that's how they answer these questions
okay so um yeah there
at some point you have to stop and what
we say in um
in the case of the rope model we say
that uh the thread
that makes up all the ropes in the
universe
there's a single thread and
this red wines around builds all the
ropes
and uh all the atoms are are
interconnected by these ropes so it's
it's the same thread it's just one
thread in the universe okay and that
one's not made of anything because that
is the primordial element that makes up
everything else hopefully there is
something like that otherwise you're an
irrational individual okay
and so here again you see the
construction okay of the atom that we
showed earlier and there you see the two
threads you can see the constructs not
only the rope but the atom itself
okay
okay so uh
let's go with the next fella here
got a couple more questions here you say
that the ropes have tension yeah what is
tension okay tension is what you see
down at the bottom it's a different
attention is not a force there's no one
winning the tug of war
that's what tension is on the other hand
force someone always wins the tug of war
force is either a push or a pull either
you go that way or that way okay you are
pulling on something and someone wins
the tug of war in the case of tension uh
you can think of it as a stick okay
that's tension okay between between my
two
fists
tension means no one wins the tug of war
there is no motion tension is a static
concept okay
and so no tension is not a force because
force is defined as someone winning the
tug of war and mainstream physicists
define it as the scalar magnitude of
tension force along an extended object
yeah i don't care how they define it
because they can't define it as a force
okay because force someone wins a tongue
of war
and he says tension is a scalar well i
don't know what scalar we don't care
about scalars we don't scale anything
okay tension is a physical concept not a
mathematical concept scalar is a
mathematical concept so please don't
bring your math into physics keep it to
yourself
okay
and i like math i i
took hundreds of math courses
i love math but has nothing to do with
physics absolutely nothing we don't use
math and physics if physically we have
to explain mechanisms especially the
invisible mechanisms that father
universe mother nature use out there god
devil whoever you pray to
once we figure that out we're done with
physics we're done with science forever
and ever and we're already at that
doorstep you know because we are the
last generation of humans on earth
pretty soon we're all gonna go
okay phil says yes we can see atoms with
the aid of an electron microscope
i used electron mass i i was certified
on a scanning electron microscope today
they have atomic force microscope
and uh you can see a lot with that
they're so great great tools
and i also use the regular microscopes
every day you know 1000 x 2000 x and so
on but then when you get to uh sums you
know you're increasing your
magnification quite a bit
never did i see an atom okay now have
other people
seen an atom well they've seen them from
a bird's eye perspective okay name what
they see is some balls some roundish
balls
and so this well says we can see atoms
and with the aid of electron microscopes
okay
uh bright guy
tell me what an atom looks like hydrogen
atom will do i mean that's the simplest
one right does it look like that is that
what your is that what you see through
your scanning electron microscope or
your atomic force microscope do you see
that a little bead going around a ball
is is that what an atom looks like
please draw your atom so that i know
what it looks like i've never seen an
atom all i always see is this on the
internet every time i look up adam you
can do this yourself look up adam see
what you get you'll get something like
this you'll get some other atoms more
complicated but essentially you get
little bead electron going around a
nucleus which is either a one ball or
several balls some of them contain
neutrons some don't is that what an atom
looks like is that what you see
or saw through the electron microscope
okay so if you can see atoms through
microscope hey please draw it don't talk
about it
show me or point to a site where i can
see it i want to see your atom
okay what it looks like i never seen an
atom
what it really looks like all we can do
is visualize and imagine what it could
look like based on its properties okay
when are you going to tell us what your
theory of cosmology and gravity is well
i had to ask this question a couple
times already so here it is fella i
don't know how you missed it okay
uh if you go to the top of my site there
you can also go to the bill gate site
either one and you'll find five
um
videos
the longest one is six minutes which is
the gravity one all the others are from
three to five minutes
and if you go there you'll find these
five videos one talks about
uh light the other one about the atom
the other one about magnetism and the
other one about electricity and you know
and you see it there so if you want to
get an introduction to my theory well
you won't spend too much time in six
minutes you'll find out what gravity is
all about according to the site
so what can i say
don't ask for it anymore just look at
that video and you'll find out
you'll get a
quick introduction to what it's like
with that i'll see you on sunday